[Music]
blue and welcome to this video which is
not strictly about the nimzo-indian and
to the group gozen but still important
to study because it's part of a general
repertoire for black against everything
Nonnie form everything that is not onee
for is kind of transpositional white can
play d4 on the first move Knight f3 on
the first move or C form and all those
moves yeah mix well together so we have
to be quite alert that if Y does not go
one d4 but and this is what we're
talking about in this video
Wednesday's playing Knight f3 that we're
not getting into some variation some
line that we have not covered in our
main line D form defenses so it's
important to have the move order
straight the other move form would be C
form that white could try and again C
form it's rather difficult to get into
the nimzo-indian Rogozin type of waters
because if we just quickly talk about
this after c4 we cannot immediately put
a pawn in the center with d5 and we get
a Queen's Gambit kind of structure we
need to start with e 6 or Knight f6 and
those moves have their drawbacks for
example Knight f6 Knight c3 and now if
we want to get into a Queen's Gambit
rogozin kind of thing we have to play a
six but now White has the option to play
E for an entirely different opening one
if we would do it differently like e6000
now we would go for this move water then
it's again difficult to get into a
Rocko's and because 90 of six white is
not obliged to play the knight to f3 we
have not as we usually do like waited
for the night to come to f3 and then
play d5 and so against c4 it is a bit
difficult to get to the lines that we
have examined in them
main chapters of this course I usually
recommend to play e5 against her 1c form
and to study these lines they had give
good chances for black to equalize and
viewed an interesting game so this video
deals with one night f3 and against this
move we have good opportunities to yeah
building a repertoire around the
nimzo-indian and the recursion what
should we play against one idea of three
there are two main candidates with our
entire d4 repertoire and that would be
one d5 or one Knight f6 both would kind
of fit defy forever is the choice in
this repertoire there is some clear
reasoning behind us if you go d5 at
first you already stake a claim in the
center with the pawn and you get a
little bit more flexibility with your
LightSquared Bishop if you play Knight
f6 first white will very often play the
move c4 after which we don't easily get
this Bishop developed of course you can
play east 65 with the hope to transpose
into the main parts of this course but
why does not obliged to play d4 now he
could I mean lucky 64 and we transpose
but he does not have to do that he can
play g3 here for example and then we are
not able to develop this actively and
this is different here with one d5 if
white now plays in a very slow way like
g3 b3 or some combination of c4 we
actually able to develop the bishop
freely so this is in a way a little bit
more active you know if you want to call
it like that here a very popular move
actually is to move d4 and then after
Knight f6 we would get into some kind of
Queen pawn opening it could again as
opposed back to a Catalan or rogozin it
happens quite often so white players
often start with 190 or 3 in order to
play d4 only on move to having avoided
many lines this was a free preview of
our entire 1.d4 course based on the
nimzo-indian and recursion available on
chess about calm thanks for watching and
see you soon
[Music]